i think i think you guys know how this
is gonna start so ready for this all
right
ready and
[Music]
guys let's welcome back
it's a dark and stormy day here in texas
i don't know what it's like over there
in california but
hopefully the sun is shining
it's a little bit smoky out a little bit
but more than that oh my god you guys
you asked for it you called down the
thunder and now you've got it we brought
peter france
in for the corridor cast i've gotten
so many comments about people wanting
to talk about peter to talk about what
he's doing
and you know this isn't just any just
hey come on our podcast and be a guest
this is a
this is a a new chapter because guys
our boys come home what do you mean by
that jake
uh what do i what do you think i mean
nick like like
he's back in l.a not only is he back
in l.a but peter has come back to
quarter digital
and uh he's going to be with us working
on videos
hopefully you know from here to whenever
until you get sick of me cradling this
means that peter is no longer an
intern yes so i think i'll pretty much
be an intern forever
i mean maybe in the hearts of the
audience but officially
not in our hearts yeah you've officially
graduated from
intern to creator
to be a part of the team and it's even
more of an honor
to be on the corridor podcast right now
uh thank you man
i mean so i think we should we should
just start for those of you who don't
know
it was a it was a hot and sh
and and sunny summer of
what year was it 2015 2016.
we put out our first ever uh
like hey submission for interns
and uh you know we got what we thought
was a lot of people at the time which
was like
a couple hundred now it's a lot for them
it was a lot for them
and we put out we put out a call and
of that you know peter submitted a video
that he was working on
called uh what was it called peter
driving force
driving force yeah and um
so we saw that and we thought man this
is this is pretty good
now came in we interviewed you and then
you immediately just showed up at the
studio and started
making videos with us and we were like
where'd this kid come from
yeah that was that was really weird that
was super intimidating coming in for the
first time because i've been watching
you guys for like
five years at that point yeah no i can
imagine
um so that's how old were you then peter
i was like 18 i think you were 18 okay
so were you coming out of high school or
were you about to start your senior year
yeah i was coming out it was my last
year
and then every year after that like
every summer
like the ticking of the seasons like the
turning of the seasons the ticking of
the clock
peter would show up he'd just come
knocking and and we'd all be we'd all be
waiting no invitations in our minds no
and every every sort of june or so you
just got the feeling and then all of a
sudden
there'd be that knock on the door yeah
it was like clone season
there's this little clone smell in there
yeah and it was like formaldehyde
it smells a lot like formaldehyde and
shampoo
yeah shampoo i'm i guess i use shampoo a
decent amount
what's the first thing i noticed about
you i'm like this guy shampoos this guy
and he's good at vfx i've actually been
shampooing less recently apparently it's
better for your hair
that's what i like over two or three
days nice
yeah secrets the shampoo industry
doesn't want you to know
exactly no sulfates you don't want soul
face peter
what um i mean i guess what what have
you seen
over these years you know it's you did
four years as an intern
and now you're with us full-time i mean
what have you seen
from your own eyes uh as as you've sort
of grown and as as
you've watched us grow as well okay
before i answer that question
i my audio is so [ __ ] i'm hearing my
own voice
oh okay yeah fix it no
it's okay the uh quarter cast we embrace
jank over here
we do um it's time for a little jank
music interlude
yeah get that mandolin do it okay there
we go i'm gonna give a second clap
what are you in e yeah yeah
yeah there you go
[Music]
did you think that you don't know what
chords you're playing but yeah
okay cool sorry about that no that's all
right um
we were talking about like coming back
every year
did you notice was it weird coming back
every summer
yeah slightly different studio i mean it
was super strange for a couple of
reasons because
for one reason it's like i would go away
and then i would watch you guys
on youtube for that whole year so i felt
like i was still hanging out with you
and then i came back and everyone's like
hey i mean you guys were all super nice
but it wasn't like we had been hanging
out for a year so it was like this weird
like disconnect um yeah yeah it's pretty
strange
i don't know if anything's happened like
that ever before
youtube and and digital media like has
like a one-way relationship that turns
two ways in certain times
it's very strange um
well you know i was looking back at some
of the old uh
vlogs when you first started with us and
i mean we were working out of
studio five mm-hmm first oh yeah yeah
i think was that your first summer yeah
it was sweat city
we didn't have air conditioning in
we decided hey you know what it's super
hot in here
let's insulate the ceiling that was our
big oh
big deal man that was our big deal we
moved into that place it didn't have any
insulation it didn't have any circuitry
on the internet
yeah it was 90 degrees every summer
albeit there were only like five people
five six people at once so
mm-hmm so we all sweated collectively
less
and it only raised the average
temperature like an extra two degrees
would you find that when there were more
people the temperature would get higher
just based on the amount of people oh
yeah
oh yeah damn it that's i mean we found
that out
i think right before you finally broke
down and bought the ac machines
i couldn't do that anymore we were like
12 people 11 people
that was like were we two years ago that
many people before i got we got ac
i think it was like that like two
summers ago right and it was like gabe
and jarrett was in the studio and
carmichael
we were all in there so it got pretty
hot maybe it wasn't that much but
so when so when we were in studio five
we were just doing the installation
in four and then i remember the day they
put an
air conditioning into that unit you got
do you were you there
when that happened oh yeah they put in
three
and and and boom they turn them all on
at the same time and it was like a dream
it was it was amazing and then we go
over to studio four
and it was like all dusty under
construction was like
haunted in there to go through the blue
tarp we have like a vlog where we're
like we have to go in and it's all hazy
and like yeah it's like so weird oh my
god
yeah that was strange so there was
nobody in the studio hardly at that time
i mean
the three of us were there but man just
every and then i started to notice like
as he'd come back every year thinking
thinking to myself man
every time peter comes back there's just
more stuff in this studio
i wonder what he thinks is going on here
yeah i mean it just seemed more
like official each time and more like
like i mean you guys have always known
what you were doing but it seems like
you got it down to a formula now
it's really impressive like each time
coming back you know
well that's good to hear because this
doesn't always feel like that
it definitely looks like a problem
sometimes
yeah sometimes it feels like we're just
flying by the seat of our pants and
sometimes we are
but uh other times not so much that's
the fun way to do it
yeah um so you've been working on
a few different videos since you
since you started with us i mean
obviously there was the summer
of spider-man oh god
that was like two summers of spider-man
right oh that was a long
project no yeah we like shot it over
that school year when i was in school
just completely disregarded academics
and shot that and then
over that summer um yeah just like every
day
in the studio i remember you jake you
would like come in at like
11 p.m to like get something out and be
like oh what's up dude
yeah it's like multiple times chugging
away okay
walk us through what that process walk
the viewers like the audience through
what that process was like for you how
did it start
how did you come up with the idea like
what was
you know yeah i mean i've always loved
spider-man i was like
raised on the sam raimi spider-man
movies oh yeah um those were like my
favorite
growing up i still really i think
spider-man 2 is probably like my
favorite movie it's just so good
but um yeah so i'd always wanted to make
one and then
i think nick and carmichael and i were
driving back from the desert when we
shot
the peter 42 clone thing where i was
like running on the one wheel
yes and then the hurrah yeah yeah dude
that was
weird but um i forget how it came up
but carmichael and i were talking about
like a spider-man video and he was like
talking about he wanted to do
one or something i was like hmm maybe
i'll do one so i was just
i had that i'll make a fully cg
spider-man film instead
exactly um so yeah i had that in my head
and then
over those next few months i was like
writing it and
i don't have the most elegant writing
process it's pretty much just like
get the bare bones of a story and then
get really excited about
the spectacle and just get caught up
with that and not
pay as much attention to the story which
i kind of pay for later
but um so yeah i wrote the script and i
was originally gonna do a kickstarter
which i'm so glad i didn't have to do
because i think yeah i called you jake
and i asked what the legality of that
was
and you were like it's probably fine but
send over your
um your script and i'd done a teaser too
and you said to send that over and i did
you guys offered to pay me the money to
make it
um which was amazing and like super
generous to you guys
the the promise was in the i think was
in the the trailer that you did and then
the thing was it was like it was about
the cost of making a youtube video
anyway
oh wow so the way that i saw it was
was just you know it was an opportunity
to say okay well
this is what it would cost to make
pretty much any youtube video to begin
with
and then also it's an opportunity for
you to continue to hone your skills and
then if we can post it
you know then it's just one it's one
more video for us it's a learning
experience for you
everyone wins yeah um so
that was i feel like it was a good good
thing for everybody
um no totally and i remember um
i forget which video it was but i
remember one time nico was talking about
how
some dude in a warehouse across from you
guys was like super generous and just
let you guys
use the warehouse and he was like i hope
you get to
pass on that favor one day and so i feel
like that was kind of the next
incarnation of that and it was it was
just really sweet of you guys and i
really appreciate it
she's using the warehouse man just you
know
um good yeah and then so then you you
shot it and then
during production didn't you lose a day
of footage
yeah didn't okay but then it turns out
sam was like oh there's an easy fix for
that like six months later and i was
like
god damn it yeah and you were shooting
on the red camera
right yeah you guys for some reason you
lent me your red camera i don't know how
you trusted me with that
i guess it was the the lesser expensive
one but uh yeah it was and i figured
that
it was like part of the you know it was
part of the shoot
and if you were gonna go up out and
shoot a video then you know we'd use a
camera
that's a good point yeah so i was
shooting on the red and i shot this
whole day footage
i like had to like this whole kitchen
scene and put up a green screen and
everything
shot and it was pretty happy with it and
then i just like put the card in the sd
the like red sd card reader and it just
like fried it or something i don't know
what happened
but yeah lost the whole day oh i had to
shoot that one again which is you still
don't know what happened
no i have no idea i think sam said it
was something with like
just a format error and there's like a
really easy fix but
i didn't know that at the time so sucks
for me i guess murphy's law
does he reshoot it so wait it's like oh
there's a fix
so you re-shot that entire day yeah yeah
i mean thankfully it was like a half day
it was just like a small like interior
scene so it wasn't too bad but
it's definitely like really frustrating
were you more were you more or less
frustrated
when you found out that there was a fix
for it or when you found out that you
had to reshoot the day
when there was a fix for it because
honestly like any chance to reshoot
something
i love because you just get another try
making it much better like
the short film i'm working on right now
we did like
a lot of reshoots and the cast and crew
weren't too happy about
it but um it's so much better now and so
yeah i really don't mind reshooting
things like because it just gives you
another chance you know
definitely so so when you uh when you
got it all in the can
about when was that because i think you
started the process
you started the shooting process when
you got into school that year so that
would have been
yeah i think we started around february
and then it ended like
like a week before the video came out or
something i had to get like
that last shot of the cake falling on
the ground or something like that so
it lasted pretty much the whole time but
when when did you finish the majority of
principal photography
principal photography yeah it was like
the last week of school i finished it
okay
so you shot from february to may
effectively substantial it wasn't like
we were shooting every day it would be
like weekends here and there you know
yeah and then uh and then
and then post started yeah yeah
[Laughter]
and so yeah with post i was like taking
my sweet old time in the beginning there
like
making that spider-man 3d model and
doing lots of tests and things
yeah and then july rolled around i was
like [ __ ] i've got like three shots done
and so i decided i'm gonna get ahead of
it and i'm gonna start coming in every
day and on weekends and staying
late and that way i won't be going right
up to the edge of the deadline
and then i went up to the deadline and i
passed the deadline
and then i passed the next deadline
that's what deadlines are for
rescheduling that's a good way to put it
that's a good way of thinking so um
so then you you didn't even have it done
when you went to school right
when you went back to school oh yeah god
it was so long ago
i just want to clarify though this was
all you working on this though right
like you were the post team as far as
yeah
i think or helps me with some roto okay
but yeah besides that
i did all the effects so you had uh is
nice
for the ego but in practice isn't that
fun
yeah did you have kind of like the
expectation of like oh i'm just gonna
like
bang this out like oh yeah
no no breaks and it seems like
that wasn't possible because we're not
no definitely not i mean
yeah i was probably like overly
ambitious with it
and had there even like 50
no not 50 like 20 more effect shots that
were going to be in it that
i think sam and ren were like just cut
those you don't need them
that's stupid um but yeah i
always make the mistake of thinking
things are going to take
like way less time than they actually
are so
it ended up biting me in the ass but i'm
happy with how it turned out so honestly
dude
yeah i mean it shows man it it really
shows thanks yeah
over ambition is a blessing i think
because you can always reign it back
you know that's a good point you can you
i feel like
there is that there's that moment though
in any project
where uh and i'm i'm feeling this now on
something i'm working on but
you start to add the layers of quality
and then you you know you do one
quality thing over on this side and then
you look back on
the other side yeah and you go wait a
minute this is completely off balance in
terms of its quality
so now i need to do i need to do that
shot and then
and then it's like oh well now that i
set that level
i need to make sure that all of all of
it is like that
um and there's there's an art i think in
no in and of two
in and of itself just understanding
where a visual and and overall quality
of a piece
should live you know just just in the
just even in the approach of something
um
because there's always the tendency to
like well i want it to be perfect
and so i'm gonna try to set out to do it
that way and then
you know you realize in july you've only
done three shots and you're like okay
well
i need to adjust this yeah um yeah
that's interesting something i found to
be really helpful
with that kind of thing is like in the
short film i'm working on now instead of
like
going through chronologically and doing
all the effects to the level of quality
that i would want them to be at i'm
doing like
bare bones versions of each shot you
know so it's more of an
iterative process and that way like if
there's any i mean i don't have a
deadline but if there was a deadline
if i needed to i could turn something in
you know and then just keep working on
it
and perfecting it but yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's a smart way to do it are you
starting with like mock-ups is it just
like really like roughed out vfx or is
it just kind of like you did like a
quick pass on it
make it passable and then if you want to
spend more time on it you can do that
later
yeah i mean i always tell myself i'm
gonna do like the shade
mock-ups with just the grayscale thing
but then i'm in the project
and i just like get too invested in it
and i'm like oh but it would look good
if i did this and so i end up rendering
like
a decent quality one when i should just
be doing like the pure animation and
then moving on so
i still get stuffed up a little bit but
it definitely helps man
well you're a one-man vfx army man i
mean
spider-man cake day was chef's kiss
thank you thank you i appreciate that
final shot
of the dropping the cake
[Music]
i think my dad suggested that so props
to my dad
nice today's episode is brought to you
by storyblocks they've sponsored this
podcast in the past and we use story
blocks
all the time around here at corridor
digital we use them
for b-roll we use them for motion
graphics we use them for sound bites
and after effects templates and more
they're our one-stop shop for all of our
stock
asset needs with an all-access unlimited
plan you can download as much
from storyblocks as you need and it's
all royalty-free so whether we're
working on a commercial
or something for youtube or just
something for us here around the studio
whatever you download from storybox you
can use across all platforms
royalty free the best part most of it
comes in beautiful 4k
and they're constantly updating their
site so every time we go on there
there's something new for us
even if you're just a video creator
that's starting out
storyblocks is something that you're
going to want to consider moving forward
the more and more videos that you make
the more and more your need for b-roll
is going to increase because there's
just there's just little moments you
know little connective tissue between
things that you're gonna need
to make moments work on camera and in
video and that's exactly what storybox
can help you do
so just head on over to storyblocks.com
corridor cast or click the link in the
description below
and you'll be able to see everything
they have to offer that's
storyblocks.com
corridorcast once again huge thanks to
them for making this podcast
continue to be possible and now back to
the
episodes and the adventures with peter
franz
uh so tell us what you're working on now
i mean you've got this little
i saw i saw it months ago don't even
think about that
erase that from your brain okay well
just tell me this is there's still a man
rollerblading
oh yeah this isn't at the beginning okay
that's all i needed to know
okay so far that was my favorite part
that's awesome because there's a lot
more of that in the in the movie now a
lot of roller blading
man that okay so yeah basically
you know i went to school in san
francisco and i really love that city
and they're having this
epidemic right now not coronavirus level
epidemic but um
kind of surface level epidemic with
scooters with elec electric scooters
getting like littered all over the place
it's honestly not that bad people are
just
freaking out about it but um yeah i
guess you guys have been like
the problem i've yeah i gotta say it's
just kind of like a 20 20 thing
if there was like a couple things that
like like in 20 years
or 30 years when they're doing like
films set in in the 20s
yeah it's gonna be like oh totally art
department's gonna be searching for
piles of [ __ ] discarded bird scooters
on the corners
yeah just like rolling up in the beach
and stuff yeah that's my favorite
instagram account is bird graveyard it's
just like
people beating the [ __ ] out of scooters
you gotta wonder how that is profitable
with all those if you're a hoarder
start saving the bird scooters now
because a movie production is going to
come along
in about 20 years and they're going to
want to they're going to want to rent
those
down from yeah i got a few filming so i
better hang on to those
okay yeah make sure you do yeah those
will be valuable one day
so yeah um they're these scooters and my
friend and i rollerblade a lot we would
always
uh go rollerblading downtown like in
between cars and stuff we would like to
do that on saturdays it was really fun
and we've always wanted to make a video
out of it this is um the guy who's the
bad guy
in spider-man okay uh the guy in the
green suit i don't know if you remember
yeah anyways his name is matt he's a
buddy of mine and um
we decided to make a movie about a
rollerblader who hates those scooters
and uh wants to get rid of them but then
happens to meet like a fully
cgi robot made out of the scooters and
they like
slowly become friends and uh they just
like
try to take down the scooter corporation
and it's a like an action comedy film
based around that
it's sentient the the skull robot and
it's fully sentient
there it gets struck by lightning
there's no explanation for it
gotcha but it's like this amalgamation
of like scooter parts
that exactly turns into a human it's
just like a bunch of little scooter
scraps and i'm
using the motion capture suit and doing
like
full body mocap for the character or is
it a solid blender
no yeah it's in blender it's um it's
this company called rococo they lent me
a suit and i'm sure gonna do some uh
promotions and stuff for them but
yeah it's amazing it's it's like the
same thing as the xn suit you guys got
oh i know yeah they're sworn enemies
actually really rococo and xs yeah
okay they're are they because they're
gonna have to fight tonight they're
gonna have to fight to the death because
sam is supposed to come over and do some
sort of live capture with them
yeah really yeah coco is okay they want
to work with sam so that's awesome you
just i show up in the doorway in my real
cocoa suit
you bring it over they're like yeah well
yeah we'll we'll
set up a live stream for friday and then
no one shows up and then
peter eerily shows up sometimes he's sam
he's in one of those
yeah hey sam um nice
sounds like motion capturing and his
model just like
switches to another mocap like
wait a second whose motion is that i'm
doing the mocap now
yeah yeah it's packed into my mo steals
your motion
oh that would be funny like in a pacific
rim type movie you know where they use
the mocaps to control the robots it's
like
someone else's
funny to like make a film about like
motion capture that controls someone
else
like oh yeah start coming oh my god
sam's actual body
well they have those exoskeletons for
the military have you seen it that's it
right there
dude and so somebody gets in a mocap
suit and somebody reminds me of the
skeleton
of like wallace and grommet uh the wrong
trousers did any of you either see
what did you guys see that yeah so
yeah yeah so same studio it's like an
animated series by i think nick park is
his name
but dude there's a scene like basically
he gets stuck in these pants that
control them
and uh he's just like a puppet yeah yeah
i've seen that
be like that but with the full
exoskeleton i love that animation style
so we should do that that's a good idea
we should do that
it's like run away i'm not getting that
capture
i thought you were going to say i'm not
going to do the effects for it i'll do
the effects i just don't want to get in
that suit i don't want to break my back
and i'll do them in a day i can do it
man
i swear so so oh go on yeah yeah so so
back to the video
you you built a a sentient
cgi that gets struck by lightning out of
parts of a scooter yep now
uh you captured all of this entirely
on set live with a mocap suit i wish i
did for the first half of shooting we
didn't have the motion capture suit
i didn't even think of that as feasible
but then i saw the
rococo people who were making that kind
of thing and um
only then did i reach out to them to get
one but they sent me one and so for the
second half of filming we had it
but then for some days we didn't like
the data got lost
so for the majority of it i'm going to
be doing it myself and just
syncing it up with the dialogue but um
for when it did work it was amazing
such a great tool to have on set what's
with you losing motion capture data
beard
what do you mean was that definitively
me did i screw that up
there's a rumor from last summer that
peter lost a bunch of mocap down
i'm so sorry i got that call from
clinton my heart just sank
i felt so bad you guys had to reshoot it
right
yeah we did and it was it was like you
said i mean every shoot it turned out
for the better but
for boston too yeah i i don't actually
know what happened with that footage
because
you know we dumped it and then it had
all the
file numbers and then all of a sudden
the file numbers just skipped
like it just just it just decided that
it wasn't going to capture
those from from like 11 a.m to like
whatever it was
just i seem to remember like they had
run into that problem before with
capture
so really you were you know whether it
was you
or someone else it wasn't the first time
it's not definitive it's
not definitive yeah so so you
just filmed somebody on set
and then you tracked them manually and
replaced them
pretty much i mean we got the person
acting on set we did it like andy circus
style or i guess irishman style because
they didn't have any tech on set
um we just like recorded them got the
clean plate and then
what i was doing for vfx was like
manually animating it to match up the
movement
but now i'm just like looking at what he
did on set with my
motion capture suit on and like trying
to roughly do it and it's a bit janky
but
it works well enough so
what about did you have did you have
moving camera shots and things like that
yeah so for that um for anything where
the camera wasn't moving we would just
have
the main actor and the guy who's gonna
be the scooter in the same shot
um because you know you can just track
in the background plate and
slap it over them but for any of the
moving camera stuff we would do the
first one
with both actors and just have them run
through it to get the choreography
and then for the second take we would
take scooter guy out
and just have him behind the camera
saying lines and then my buddy matt just
acting with nothing
okay and did you find that you're you're
mostly using that second take then
in the animation pretty sorry in the
actual edit yeah
i mean interesting yeah that's really
cool man it's
it's really interesting to hear
everyone's like motion capture work
flows for onset
like what works what doesn't work yeah
yeah i mean i learned a lot from you
guys shooting the boss down video that
was really helpful
yeah that was a whole whole thing in
itself
if if there was one thing that you
picked up that you would like
want to pass on to anyone trying to
shoot mocap on set
what would it be from this project just
take your time
getting it set up because sometimes you
know with the shoot it's like
time's running out and you gotta get
something you gotta get a shot and a lot
of the time
on set i would be like we'll just use
motion capture later yeah get flustered
and
just decide to do it later or something
but
it's just never as good doing it later
because if you have two actors in the
same scene
they can play off of each other and it
just feels a lot more like the scenes
where we actually got the motion capture
on set
it feels much more natural than when i'm
doing it later
so definitely everything you can do to
get it done on set is
super helpful now um
what kind of post nightmare did you set
yourself up for here
i mean how long is the piece it's
22 minutes 22 minutes
yeah it's 22 minutes yeah
oh my god why didn't you just go and
make it an hour and a half at this point
i mean if someone will buy it and give
me the money to make an hour and a half
i
i would love to if a quarter wants to do
a corridor website original
i wouldn't say no but um
so and and throughout what 10
10 or more minutes you have this robot
in every shot
probably like 20 minutes
he's in the shop 20 out of 22 minutes
you have a robot
you're crazy yeah i mean honestly like
it's i mean i'm gonna
i hate myself for saying this later but
it's not too bad because you know
the workflow is um basically just like i
edit it i have
the footage of the dude in the edit with
the clean plate underneath and so
when i go to the vfx for a scene i just
bring the whole
clean plate into the shot bring in the
mocap data and bring in the audio
and then i just record the mocap data
track the shot
light it and render it there's really no
like extra tweaking i have to do which
is nice
yeah what about the model itself that's
already done and rigged and does all the
work
once you got it okay yeah i was using
this really cool software called
substance painter
i don't know if anybody in the studio
uses it but it's really cool you
basically just like
bring in your 3d model and it calculates
like the edges of things and where there
are crevices and things like that so it
can put like
like uh the edge of like something
that's metal that was painted it can
have like the paint shift
chipped off on the edges so it just adds
like a lot of little uh
nice details okay yeah did you use that
on uh willy wonka are rated is that
where i've heard of that before
or did i i don't think i did okay
maybe it was wren who told me about it
but probably i think sounds like a
really cool program
so if you're working with us now um
when are you gonna finish this thing is
this something that do we need to do
another thing here where you
distribute this on corridor or what what
do we
how do we work this in here yeah i mean
i don't know man
the the current plan is to just work
nights and weekends on it because
i wouldn't want it to cut into to
corridor time
but uh i definitely think about that you
know it would be awesome
having that kind of audience for it yeah
i guess we'll have to see how good it is
huh
i guess so it's definitely better than
what you saw so
so don't worry about that okay well
that's encouraging because what i saw
wasn't bad
um i was i was you know i was able to
put on my cg goggles and
you know see through it
but yeah you have a little bit of
credibility built up you know
yeah yeah you've done a couple vfx
related things in the past
not much timeline credibility but some
results credibility
i mean results are all that matters so
now that um
you know now that we've got sort of uh
an unlimited time frame here
um i'd love to hear well actually from
both you and nick like
nick you've sort of been the auteur
of these rated r pieces you know you
you've been the guy that's sort of been
like directing the group and and sort of
coming up with the overall cuts for him
i mean the stuff you did with willy
wonka the stuff you did with home alone
all that stuff was very very much
additive
from the original property i mean is
there something now
with peter with wren with clinton
uh sam nico obviously matt i mean we
have a whole stable now
of of artists and pretty much
when it comes to like re-adapting
stuff sure there's almost a limit
limitless universe in which we can
yeah i mean certainly there's some more
rated r
ideas and i look forward to you know
getting together with you peter and the
rest of the vfx boys and
hammer and some out we have a couple
ideas for some upcoming ones we have
star trek
which we're super excited about yeah um
i think there's it's like just waiting
to be made rated r
because you know it was and this is the
original one made back in the day so
it was i mean a just the standards of
violence and like action were just so
much different
back then so like everything is and you
know the cameras are locked off in wide
shots for
almost all the action it's like i wonder
what we could bring to this
uh that could make it a little bit more
of our age
so didn't they used to do the beam me up
scotty effect with like putting sparkles
and water
[Music]
where we do effects like that yes
there's special effects visual effects
yeah exactly yeah coming out this
weekend actually i'm not sure when this
episode's dropping but the next vfx
artist react number 33
we covered uh 2001 a space odyssey
it was like the end scene when he's
going through the wormhole
uh there's like this really cool it's
called slit scan uh
technique i think and we want to do
something where we recreate that so i
think like
i mean i'm just stoked to have you on
board you know because
obviously you're a vfx talent but all
the i feel like we can
really expand on some of these ideas of
like hands-on v-effects like
recreating old ideas um we don't have to
limit ourselves to our rated so those
are fun though
i mean yeah yeah watching those star
wars documentaries about how they did
those effects in camera it's crazy i
think that would be a really fun
series to pursue you know like go and
see if we can
recreate and maybe add to any of these
old old techniques
so yeah yeah man i i'm we're only gonna
be the stronger for having you on it's
it's about time gosh dang come on gosh
dang time boys
well i appreciate that it's uh it's an
honor honor
honor to be back yeah we can't shoot you
with arrows anymore though
there is an idea that we had to do uh to
do
to do a vfx with um like first version
yeah yes um and to see if it
can actually oh you mean like cs like
css1
bro after effects version one yeah you
get it set up on
a system that'll that'll run it and then
you
you see what you can do with it you just
have to look at
yeah so it would be fun to just see like
who can make like the craziest vfx shot
you know we should we should be called
andrew kramer actually
just in general that episode how you
doing man yeah
hey man how are you doing how's the kids
good good okay all right well i just
wanted to say hi
later oh also do you want to help us
with this video okay
i would love to get andrew kramer like
involved in
our next star rated or you know oh that
would be awesome just
like maybe one of those old school vfx
videos as well that could be really fun
totally um yeah it would be good he'd be
particularly though he'd be good for
that
using old software to do modern vfx
because
obviously interesting probably knows
more about those than
the developers oh yeah those first few
tutorials he did were in like
after effects cs negative of 500 bc
so negative 500
what version is that oh it's uh
bc version honestly that's the whole
adobe suite
this is uh bc versions oh yeah um
interesting interesting tidbit on visual
effects and special effects we've been
talking a lot about them
a lot of people don't know uh visual
effects and special effects are
different
uh yeah um visual effects is often
often used uh with the same
in the same sentence as cgi um but
what that means specifically visual
effects and special effects special
effects are
are effects that are captured in camera
meaning that you
point the camera at something and
something
happens in the real world something
special happens yes
so whether that's smoke or a an actual
squib
or an actual explosion or what have you
um and then you take that footage
and you put it into your final shot
whether or not you
you meddle with it or do anything else
with it after is is a separate thing but
this special that's what the special
effects are and then visual effects are
when you take footage and then you add
things
on top of the footage in post once
you're once you've already captured it
so
we get a lot of questions about that out
of the way yeah get that out of the way
yeah and yeah which is also sfx so it's
all it's all confusing yeah and then
there's super confusing nomenclature
when you talk about
sound effects being sfx
and then sfx also means makeup like
special effects right that's also in
that category
yes that's true yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
now that we're all uh working
and working together and we're working
from home do you guys foresee
you guys foresee any issues with that or
dude i got
a wi-fi from negative 500 bc
you're not um are you on that mcdonald's
wifi
because nick's been on that mcdonald's
wi-fi i was for a while i was for a
while and then i upgraded i got that
wendy's wi-fi now
it's better but yeah a little bit better
but i don't know i'm personally man i'm
looking forward to when we can all work
in the studio again yeah i've been
working from home
for the last like year doing uh
freelance vfx
and so it's sweet i finally get to like
go and have a
have co-workers in a work environment go
work at corridor and then
nope it's so weird i think i mean
you can speak to that but i'm sure we've
hired a lot of new people in the last
couple months
since this thing's been going on and it
must be crazy odd for them as well i
mean
it's like i mean like for daniel
like who came on to do the vlogs i know
he watched the vlogs for a long time and
he was kind of in your shoes
as well where it was like you have
someone who has a perspective of like
being a fan coming in
and then they come in and it's like no
one's in the studio ever it's like yeah
we're filming out of there all the time
yeah so people are wondering like
like then you see all of our videos and
we're in the studio it's because we go
there to film things together
um but then when we do posts we usually
do posts from home
yeah and i think it's been a it's been a
good compromise for this you know how
can we
keep making stuff and still
be safe and aware of the coronavirus you
know
right um it is i think you know
kind of confusing and maybe triggering
to some people though seeing us in the
studio filming and i get it i totally
get it
no it's triggering me yeah yeah cause
like you know because
we are we basically made a agreement
with each other
which was like let's try our best to
keep our personal bubbles
to our work like us at work and you know
significant others and you know like
me and christian and clint went out of
town last week and we had to get tested
before coming back into the studio with
everyone so like
we're trying to be conscious of it but
yeah i mean that seems like the smartest
way to do it because
corridor is a small company and it seems
like uh as long as everybody's keeping
their bubbles small it's
perfectly safe yeah yeah yeah
so yep and then anytime you go and do
something extra like
people have been going and getting
tested and then you know we have green
scratch
yeah and people have um
we're gonna have extra people come on
set in october here when we
when we do a few of these productions so
we'll have to make sure
like i'm just thinking you know we just
have people
a few days beforehand get tested then we
do temperatures and everything
yeah on set and then you know um but
other than that it's been working pretty
well um yeah knock on wood
it has our safety precautions have kept
us safe so far knock on wood adobe
get out of here yeah adobe's cousin the
the god of uh
oh god endemic
corona corona
[Laughter]
we are finishing studio three though so
one so excited
so hopefully towards the end of the year
next year what have you once
once you know things start to level back
out uh
people will be able to use that more and
more um we will be
moving the stuff into there this is
another announcement for the croutons
uh we'll be moving stuff up into studio
three in october
so soon yes it's right around the corner
um and uh steve went in there the other
day
and we have was wait
was steve what was his reaction was it
angry
or was it like happy what was it well i
mean like
was it like holy [ __ ] i like what you've
done with the place
i think i think he overall he likes what
we've done with the place
because it's you know it's it's gonna
ultimately it helps him too you know
yeah because if we're not in there
ideally we're in there for you know the
indefinite future but if any day we're
not in there he's
then he has this really nice studio that
he can lease out
um so i don't think he's too upset about
it but i was talking to guillermo and
guillermo didn't say
like yeah steve came by uh he had some
things to say but
that's how he phrased it he has some
things to say it's going to be like
night and day from
the old janky like loft that it was i
can't wait
i went in there like two weeks ago and i
saw it yeah you guys had all the
dividers like the uh little cubicle
dividers
[Laughter]
lights and every cubicle has a manager
yep
um little kitten posters with in fact mr
incredible
and you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna make phone calls out of there all
day
and uh you're gonna be excited to cut
out at 4 30. oh god
i'm going to like hear footsteps behind
me and then i'm just gonna like feel
jake's presence looking over my shoulder
i feel like we need a tps report
i pop up over a cubicle yeah
yeah no uh i think it's like a cubicle
in the best sense of the term because
it's like a it's a bull pen yeah it's
basically just wire management
in a wall lots of
ac power cords for our computers and
stuff so that's really good
because we i just wanted to like kind of
put channels
together you know in general and so
like different ways yeah that way like
nick's not yelling
across the floor to dean you know
like there's a certain level of logic
there i'm gonna miss that
honestly the chaos it's gonna be
different but there's still gonna be
chaos don't worry i mean look we're
still
all gonna be in a room working together
it's just we're gonna be in a different
room
there's just gonna be more rooms really
when you wanna film if you you have
you have on this on the new
post-production floor
you have the right to tell somebody to
shut the [ __ ] up and go to the
yeah go to the shooting floor like it
just gives us a place to banish people
yeah it's like yeah you guys filming go
go
into the other studio it's legit is a a
problem
like currently and it has been for the
last year and more than that just like
when you're shooting there's so many
things going on that you often have to
be like
guys quiet like right and now we have
another room that you can
do and it's never easy because it always
like throws off the people you're
telling they're always in some
passionate creative discussion or
something and
it can be a little bit hindering so at
least we'll have spaces to do that now
and then people's feelings get hurt and
then we have to have a conference about
it
and we have to bring in a mockery one
time jake there was
one time where he told me to be quiet
and i was really i was really engaged
with a conversation with sam
and you told me to quiet on set and i i
never recognized i lost it
there you go i trashed the studio yeah
dude
show up at night when everyone's gone
and just trash
oh my goodness yeah
so hopefully that won't happen
no promises do you think one day like
the corridor office is going to be like
some big futuristic building and it'll
be like all chrome like on top of
everything's floating yeah dude it's
going to be
you know i mean you know about the
brickest nick
oh do i know about the brickest do you
know about the brickest feeder
the brickest yes so we can't
even a common theme even if even if the
building is
in a spaceship in another galaxy
we still have to keep the brick because
of course
because that's the whole vibe yeah yeah
it's like the white such
brick yeah now steve's cool hanging out
when steve
went to go and get everything like re
re-registered or whatever he
the guy that uh was signing off on
building build vector yeah yeah the
building inspector was a
was a was a grade a brick certified
institutionalized brickish
he hates him he can't stand them he
thinks they're
they kill people i mean they do they're
dangerous especially in california which
is like we have a lot of seismic
activities
to his credit we got a ton of seismic
activity and the brick buildings have
been falling down for decades killing
people but dude
you can't quite get that like relaxed
like drake and josh's room
like hanging out vibe from like a
plaster wall you can't do it you know
like it's just what you're getting you
got some steel
some steel and some plastic
yeah i mean get out of here get out of
here
you want the brick um so
so we had to deal with that but you know
as long as we keep the brick i think
steve's steve's gonna be happy
you know it'll keep the brickists away
too yeah some people are just ignorant
i hope steve lives as long as as he
possibly can
but i hope also that when he dies part
of his spirit
comes and haunts the building i think
it's already haunting the building
dude steve's been dead for 20 years
back at the videos there's a shot of
just nothing
okay so i do have one one final topic
here oh
now getting serious peter i don't know
if you've thought about this okay so
so answer carefully jesus
bringing springing a question on you
that you did not know i was gonna ask
when we bring in the next intern
okay now do you have
words of advice for them are you going
to treat them you're bringing them in
and then
you're not interning i haven't even
this is my first day and you're already
the ink hasn't even dried
and you're bringing in another intern i
mean we can keep you as
intern officially if you want but you're
gonna have to get used to moving into
employee status peter i know it's gonna
be weird oh
god all right i guess so he's been with
us for like 20 years
can i get you guys a coffee or anything
peter drop the intern gag man
[Laughter]
damn advice for a future intern yeah um
i don't know i guess relax
i i mean i'm an anxious person so like
coming into the studio for the first
time i was like
constantly like anxiety level at a 10
because i like looked up to you guys so
much
i had watched you for five years and so
it was like really scary all of that
over the course of the last five years
totally totally jaded yeah um
but no i mean to a future intern
you'll get used to it relax it's gonna
be scary but you'll be fine
um are you gonna treat them harder than
we
needed you i'm gonna be borderline
emotionally abusive
okay yeah okay and you've all been
warned
yeah and based on how y'all treated me
that's saying something because
yeah we killed all the listeners
yeah it was brutal we're taking a step
forward yeah
from physical death to only emotionally
abusive i feel like that's a step in the
right direction
yeah yeah was it weird when you came
like when you had to sign the contract
initially and jake was like
can you just sign over your dna to us
was that odd
in it like yeah well i thought it was a
dnr which i
uh exceeded a rookie mistake i told you
you'd fall for it dude
yeah because the r and the a they look
so similar
gotcha so well and dnr means do not
resuscitate
yeah and that i'm fine with yeah yeah
yeah well we didn't
but so you thought nothing was
suspicious when i had you go to that
clinic that one day to get your dna
i just figured it was like some kind of
um it was a vfx test like vaccination
type thing you know
didn't know if anybody in the studio had
like an autoimmune disorder or anything
um yeah they like took like like this
much blood
it was yeah it's necessary man
dr pepper bottle with my blood it was a
really weird clinic they stuffed it in a
in one of those mini fridge freezers i
don't
this is weird yeah yeah well
i mean this version of you you know is
the best version we've had so far so i
think it was all for the best
and yeah yeah dude i think that's a
great way to put it nick
this version of you is the best and just
you know on a more serious note it's
been awesome to see you grow
uh as an individual as a creator um
and uh you know if you guys have
um videos that you'd like to see now
that
now that we've got peter france
officially in the crew
um let us know in the comments uh and
uh yeah peter man um this is gonna be
great this is you know hopefully the
start of
many many other projects many other mems
any other experiences
so yeah i mean it's an honor you guys
are super
genuine funny dudes and it's always a
pleasure hanging out so
god i get to do that for the indefinite
future hell yeah heck yeah man i'm
excited for what we're gonna make
lots of cool stuff coming out
all righty and uh don't forget to head
over to
corridordigital.com and uh check out one
of those subscriptions
you know dude just think about it just
it's just a suggestion about it
not not not required not required we're
just considering heavy listening
but consider it you know for all the
benefits that you get
the producer points you know the 50 off
merch
um this is christian's just gonna slowly
fade out and i'm just gonna keep hitting
talking points
all right um cool all right well guys um
on to the next one sweet it's been an
honor dude thanks for joining us
everyone
slowly fade